aktionen sorgen bernd
meine damen und herren bitte schauen sie
nicht weg wenn in unserem land schon
wieder ein bernd ausgegrenzt wird
sie wissen sicher bernd hocke ist seit
jahren einer der wichtigsten
medienpartner der heute-show deswegen
jetzt nicht im heute-show fanshop unsere
solidarität buttons bern bleibt
und natürlich die beliebten jazz wie
bernd mützen damit versammeln wir uns ab
jetzt jeden dienstag um genau 19 33 auf
dem reichsparteitagsgelände in nürnberg
und rufen gemeinsam
ja es ist doch so frauke petry der meute
diese ganzen einer losen schwach
strohlager in der afc
die wollen doch auch die stimmen der
nazis aber sie waren sie nicht die hände
schmutzig machen nur unser bernd hier
der geht dahin wo die braune suppe am
nächsten ist
bernd höcker ist gelernter
geschichtslehrer und wie ihr liebe
zuschauer haben es tatsächlich geschafft
eine seiner ehemaligen schülerinnen
aufzutreiben herzlich willkommen
kriemhild kebekus
himmel
schön dass du da bist
ja himmelt würdest du sagen im
nachhinein der bernd hat dein leben
positiv beeinflusst aber absolut ich bin
ja heute noch aktiv in der hecke jugend
toll zusammen mit meinen blonden kindern
die an diane und bianca herr welke es
wird gerade süffigem eines zeug über den
bernd verbreitet ich hatte ihn damals in
geschieht und sport oder wie er es
nannte kraft durch freude
ich kann ja heute noch den ring der
nibelungen tanja muss aber nicht
ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber da geht es immer mit mir durch ich
kann nur sagen er war ein toller lehrer
wir haben bei ihm im unterricht alles
zur deutschen geschichte gelernt
barwasser goethe schiller bismarck
erster weltkrieg
und dann kam auch schon die ddr und
dazwischen wieder zwischen zwischen
ersten weltkrieg und ddr
ach so ja sie mal wie die polin damals
den zweiten weltkrieg angefangen haben
wir natürlich augen und jetzt mal
ehrlich was war denn bitte so schlimm an
berns dresdner rede über die bomben auf
die deutschen städte hat er lediglich
gesagt zitat man wollte uns mit stumpf
und stiel vernichten
man wollte unsere wurzeln roten obwohl
wir gar nichts gemacht
ja obwohl und zusammen mit der dann nach
1945 begonnenen systematischen
umerziehung hat man das auch fast
geschafft man hat uns nämlich einfach
entnazifiziert ja ohne zu fragen
hier sind die eigentlichen opfer in der
geschichte das wird gerne vergessen
wirklich ich denke manchmal der bernd
ist der einzige
dennoch erkennt woher das problem liegt
das große problem ist dass deutschland
das europa ihre männlichkeit verloren
habe
ich sage wir müssen unseren ähnlichkeit
wieder in deckeln
das war bei ihm oft hausaufgabe wir
mussten wir mussten übers wochenende
unserer männlichkeit entdecken
da haben die mädchen meistens eine
fünfte kriegen aber die hatten wir auch
verdient natürlich ja liebe zuschauer
ist das opfer einer beispiellosen linken
hexenjagd bitte bestellen sie jetzt die
doppel langspielplatte mit den größten
hits der aktion sorgen bernd zwei
reichsmark den direkt an die deutsche
band hilfe genießen sie unvergessene
hits wie oh ja sie lernt
zuhause deutschland oder china
und natürlich
[Musik]
das war sinn
wir haben eine chance
chieming kebekus vielen dank
[Applaus]